simone veil she was a heap the age of 89 a
french politician she left a
deep mark on public life
first elected woman president of
the european parliament in 1979 she
defended federalist and supranational positions there
ray thank you all
for the  great proof of the confidence that
you are going to give by appointing to this
eminent position when I took office
the European parliament was
not known at all and I had really been in
a way an emblem and aroused a
great deal of interest  not
for me personally but to bring
the parliament back to life in 2011 the
european parliament paid homage to him
during his lifetime
by christening the square at the foot of
these buildings in brussels with his name
more than one and a half million
murdered human beings
simone veil with a childhood marked by
the second jewish world war she
survived eight months in the hell of the
extermination camp of auschwitz
the duty of memory university  e to this
tragedy was one of his fights
for this purpose this very great purpose
that it could not happen again
for me there was only one chance
it was europe reconciliation
simone veil without spreading his action
will remain  in history as a symbol
of progress brotherhood and peace